for this week's pet project lori herron
joins us from the nspca she brought
along someone who needs a safe and good
home
and another cat this one named kiwi
this is kiwi
she is in the early stages of kidney
disease so we need somebody
who will give her the proper food which
is a prescription diet of kidney food
some supplements and then she also needs
sub-q fluids twice a week which is
something that might sound scary but
it's not we can teach you how to do it
it's not expensive and it's something
that kiwi really needs she would be a
wonderful companion for
mature children we don't know her
history with other dogs and cats right
now
and she could be a really good fit for a
lot of families out there
and it has to be a special someone
that's willing to accept that
responsibility
and give kiwi what she needs to make her
comfortable yeah a little extra care
needed for kiwi
you're focusing a lot on cats this month
we are well you know kendall there's a
lot of cats
roaming the streets in southern nevada
and kiwi was one of them
kiwi was brought to us by one of our
wonderful
uh rescue transfer partners where we
were able to give her the medical care
that
she needed to make her adoptable and
there's just so many cats out there
that need home so we're featuring a lot
of cats yes
as the weather's getting warmer and of
course you're going to see more of them
as the kittens start coming of age to be
adopted as well so
a lot of cats in need in southern nevada
kendall well we love seeing all the
animals that need a good home and we
hope
they find that if you're interested
thank you lori if you're interested in
adopting a pet
you can go to nevadaspca.org or call
them
at that phone number 702-873-7722
we'll be right back